Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Miller Lite. The light beer brewed for people who love the taste of beer, and the perfect pairing for your game time. When Miller Lite set out to brew a light beer, they had to choose great taste or 90 calories per can. They chose both because they knew the best part of beer is the beer. Your game time tastes like Miller time. Learn more at MillerLite.ca. Must be legal drinking age.
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先听系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。米勒淡啤（Miller Lite）。为热爱啤酒口感的人们酿造的淡啤，您比赛时光的绝佳伴侣。当米勒 Lite 着手酿造一款淡啤酒时，他们必须在极佳的口感和每罐 90 卡路里之间做出选择。他们两者兼得，因为他们深知啤酒最美好的部分就是啤酒本身。你的比赛时光，品味米勒时刻。了解更多请访问 MillerLite.ca。须达到法定饮酒年龄。
In a darkly comedic look at motherhood and society's expectations, Academy Award-nominated Amy Adams stars as a passionate artist who puts her career on hold to stay home with her young son. But her maternal instincts take a wild and surreal turn as she discovers the best, yet fiercest part of herself. Based on the acclaimed novel, Nightbitch is a thought-provoking and wickedly humorous film from Searchlight Pictures. Nightbitch is now streaming only on Disney+.
探路者影业（Searchlight Pictures）推出了一部黑色幽默风格的影片，聚焦母职与社会的期望。获得奥斯卡奖提名的艾米·亚当斯（Amy Adams）在片中饰演一位充满激情的艺术家，为了照顾年幼的儿子，她暂时搁置了自己的职业生涯。然而，随着她发现自己身上最好却也最炽烈的一面，她的母性本能经历了一场疯狂而超现实的转变。改编自广受好评的小说，《长牙之夜》（Nightbitch）是一部引人深思且邪恶幽默的电影。《长牙之夜》现已在 Disney+ 独家上线。
Parents, when you visit California, childhood rules. If you don't remember how awesome childhood is, just ask yourself, what would kids do? Let childhood rule your family vacation. Start planning your trip to the ultimate playground If you don't remember how awesome childhood is, just ask yourself, What would kids do? Let childhood rule your family vacation. Start planning your trip to the ultimate playground at visitcalifornia.com Now all Nero's attendants urged him to place himself beyond the reach of the indignities that were closing in on M. And so he ordered them, as he watched, to dig a hole the size
各位家长，当您造访加利福尼亚时，童趣当道。如果您不记得童年有多么美好，只需问问自己：孩子们会怎么做？让童趣主导您的家庭假期。开始规划您前往终极游乐场的旅程 如果您不记得童年有多么美好，只需问问自己，孩子们会怎么做？让童趣主导您的家庭假期。在 visitcalifornia.com 开始规划您前往终极游乐场的旅程 此时，尼禄（Nero）的所有随从都敦促他，让自己免遭那些正步步紧逼的侮辱。于是他命令他们在自己注视下，挖一个大小恰好能容纳
of his body, and to collect such fragments of marble as could be found and to bring water and firewood ready for the disposal of what would very soon be his corpse. And as these things were being done, so he wept, and cried repeatedly, That I should die a mere artisan! When during the delay caused by these preparations, a letter was brought to his freedman by courier, he snatched it, and learned by reading it it that the Senate had proclaimed him a public enemy and ordered a search made for him so that he might be punished according to the ancestral fashion.
他身体的洞，并收集所能找到的大理石碎片，准备好水和柴火，以便随时处理很快就会成为尸体的他。在做这些事情的同时，他哭泣着，反复喊道：“我竟要死得像个普通的工匠！”就在这些准备工作导致耽搁期间，一名信使将一封信送到他的解放奴隶手中，他一把抢过来，读后得知元老院已宣布他为国家公敌，并下令搜捕他，以便按照祖制对其实施惩罚。
And when, after asking what this punishment might be, he learned that a man sentenced to it would be stripped naked, have his neck put in a fork, and then be beaten to death with rods. So terror-stricken was he that he grabbed two daggers he had brought with him and tested the blades of both, after which, on the grounds that the fatal hour had not yet arrived, he put them away again. But then came the horsemen, who had been commissioned to bring him back alive, closing in upon him. When he heard their approach, he said in a shaking voice, quoting Homer,
在打听这种惩罚是什么时，他得知被判处此刑的人将被剥光衣服，脖子套上木枷，然后用棍棒活活打死。他惊恐万分，抓起随身带来的两把短匕首，试了试两把刀的锋利度，随后又以死期未到为由将它们收了回去。但就在这时，奉命将他活捉回去的骑兵正步步逼近。听到他们的脚步声，他声音颤抖地引用荷马的诗句说道：
The thundering of swift-footed horses echoes in my ears. Whereupon, with the assistance of his secretary Epaphroditus, he slit his throat. Although still on the margins of consciousness when a centurion came bursting in and pretending to have come with the aim of helping him held a cloak up to staunch his wound, he only muttered, Too late? And such loyalty? With these words, he died, and so fixedly did his eyeballs bulge from their sockets that onlookers were filled with horror and dread.
“疾蹄奔腾之声响在我的耳畔。”随后，在他的秘书埃帕弗罗迪图斯（Epaphroditus）的协助下，他割断了自己的喉咙。虽然当一名百夫长冲进来、假装前来帮忙并举起斗篷试图帮他止血时，他尚存一丝意识，但他只是喃喃道：“太迟了？这就是忠诚吗？”说罢，他便咽了气，他的眼球从眼窝中凸显得如此死板，以至于旁观者都充满了惊恐与畏惧。
So that tremendous passage is describing the death of Nero on the 9th of June 68. It was written by the Roman scholar Gaius Suetonius Tranquillus in his great collection of biographies, The Lives of the Caesars, The Twelve Caesars, depending on what you call it. And I'm delighted to say that that was translated by a top amateur translator. And that gifted young amateur, Tom, is yourself because this is your new translation of Suetonius coming out in Penguin Classics on the 13th of February. Very exciting. Thanks Dominic. It is and I believe is available for pre-order so everyone fill your boots. Yeah. So the lives of the Caesars as you said, I mean they are probably along with the
这段精彩绝伦的文字描述的是尼禄于公元68年6月9日的死。它是由罗马学者盖乌斯·苏埃托尼乌斯·特朗库利乌斯（Gaius Suetonius Tranquillus）在其伟大的传记合集《罗马十二帝王传》（The Lives of the Caesars, The Twelve Caesars，取决于你如何称呼它）中写下的。我很高兴地说，那是被一位顶级业余翻译翻译的。而那位才华横溢的年轻业余爱好者，汤姆，就是你自己，因为这是你对苏埃托尼乌斯的新译本，将于2月13日在企鹅经典（Penguin Classics）出版。非常令人兴奋。谢谢多米尼克。确实是的，我相信它已经可以预订了，所以大家快去买吧。是的。所以正如你所说，十二帝王传，我的意思是它们可能与
biographies written by Plutarch, the most celebrated of all the biographies that we've received from the ancient world. And these I think are without doubt the most glamorous, the most scabrous occasionally, the most shocking. And as you said, they describe the lives of 12 Caesars and they range from the life of Julius Caesar, who was born in 100 BC, up to the Emperor Domitian who died in 1896. So that's covering two centuries, probably the most dramatic, the most spectacular two centuries in all of Roman history. And these are rulers who in succession were the most powerful men in the Roman Empire. So we're at the heart
普鲁塔克（Plutarch）撰写的传记一起，是我们从古代世界流传下来的所有传记中最著名的。而且我认为，这些无疑是最迷人的、有时也是最粗俗的、最令人震惊的。正如你所说，它们描述了12位凯撒的生平，时间跨度从公元前100年出生的尤利乌斯·凯撒（Julius Caesar）一直到公元96年去世的图密善（Domitian）皇帝。所以这涵盖了两个世纪，可能是整个罗马历史上最戏剧化、最壮观的两个世纪。这些统治者先后都是罗马帝国最有权势的人。所以我们正处于权力
of power. Yeah. So let's just run through very quickly for those people who don't know. We kick off with Julius Caesar crosses the Rubicon., sorta topples the Republic, but famously is not the first emperor, as everybody thinks. So he's the one we kick off with, then it's Augustus, the first emperor, arguably the greatest politician in Western history, who establishes the template for what follows. Then we have Tiberius. We will be doing an episode about Tiberius, won't we?
的核心。是的。那么，对于那些不太了解的人，我们快速过一遍。我们从尤利乌斯·凯撒跨越卢比肯河开始，某种程度上推翻了共和国，但众所周知，他并不是像大家所想的那样是第一位皇帝。所以他是我们开篇的主角，然后是奥古斯都（Augustus），第一位皇帝，可以说是西方历史上最伟大的政治家，他确立了后续统治的模板。然后是提比略（Tiberius）。我们会做一期关于提比略的节目，对吧？
We will. And of how would you describe him in a sentence? Grizzled, experienced general who misbehaves on the island of Capri. Or does he? Right. We will be exploring that in our next episode. And he is then succeeded by Caligula. Mad. Yeah. We'll be doing an episode on him. Yeah. Claudius, we'll be doing an episode on him. And then Nero, who we've just been hearing about. With Nero's death, the family of Augustus comes to an end. You then have a year of bloodshed and civil war, AD 69, when four emperors in succession rule. So that is Galba, Otho, Vitellius and Vespasian. And again, Suetonius describes the lives of all four men. It's Vespasian who establishes himself as emperor.
我们会做的。如果要用一句话来形容他，你会怎么说？饱经风霜、经验丰富的将军，在卡 Capri（卡布里）岛上行为不端。真的是这样吗？没错。我们将在下一期节目中探讨这一点。接着继承他皇位的是卡利古拉（Caligula）。疯子。是的。我们会做一期关于他的节目。是的。克劳狄乌斯（Claudius），我们会做一期关于他的节目。然后是我们刚刚听说的尼禄。随着尼禄的死，奥古斯都的家族走到了尽头。随后迎来了充满流血和内战的一年，即公元69年，当时有四位皇帝相继统治。也就是加尔巴（Galba）、奥托（Otho）、维特里乌斯（Vitellius）和韦斯帕芗（Vespasian）。苏埃托尼乌斯同样描述了这四个人的生平。正是韦斯帕芗确立了自己的皇帝地位。
He establishes a new dynasty and is succeeded by his two sons in turn. So first Titus and then Domitian. And we begin, Julius Caesar, as you said, is born into a Rome that is still a republic and Domitian is an emperor who demands that the Romans call him Dominus, master. So that is essentially kind of the evolution from a republican system to a much more autocratic system. So the fascination of these stories is both that they describe the evolution of Rome, so from republic to empire. But the other element of it is the extraordinary vividness and richness of the lives that it describes and the details. So many of the things that people best know, that people immediately reach for about the Roman emperors, particularly the sex and violence, many of
他建立了一个新王朝，并由他的两个儿子相继继承。先是提图斯（Titus），然后是图密善。正如你所说，我们开始时，尤利乌斯·凯撒出生在一个仍然是共和国的罗马，而图密善则是一位要求罗马人称他为主宰（Dominus，即主人）的皇帝。所以这本质上是从共和体制向更加专制体制的一种演变。因此，这些故事的魅力既在于它们描述了罗马的演变，也就是从共和国到帝国的转变；但另一个要素是它所描述的生平和细节具有非凡的生动性和丰富性。人们最了解的、对罗马皇帝的第一反应的许多事情，尤其是性和暴力，其中许多
these things come from these biographers, don't they? So we mentioned Tiberius. So Tiberius, when he's in retirement, unbelievable sexual depravity, or is it, on the island of Capri, or Nero, or Caligula, I mean, these stories all come from Suetonius by and large, don't they? Or Caesar crossing the Rubicon, or Caesar being murdered. And in fact, the assassination of Caligula in his own palace, the murder of Phytelius in AD 69, I mean, kind of being sliced up like sashimi on the steps leading up from the Forum to the Capitol. He's completely fascinated by how emperors meet their deaths. But important to emphasize as well that he's
事情都来自这些传记作家，对吧？所以我们提到了提比略。提比略在退位后，在卡布里岛上有令人难以置信的性堕落，或者真的是这样吗？或者尼禄，或者卡利古拉，我的意思是，这些故事大体上都来自苏埃托尼乌斯，对吧？或者凯撒跨越卢比肯河，或者凯撒被谋杀。事实上，卡利古拉在自己的宫殿中被暗杀，维特里乌斯在公元69年被谋杀，我的意思是，从广场通往卡皮托利山的台阶上，他像生鱼片一样被切碎。他对皇帝们如何走向死亡有着彻底的着迷。但同样重要的是要强调，他
fascinated essentially in pretty much everything. I mean, there is almost no detail that he doesn't explore. So we see the Caesars rather as we might kind of contemporary politicians in a political context. So we see them, you know, wrestling with, I don't know, PR scandals or funding shortfalls or foreign policy crises. And we're shown their tastes, their foibles, the kind of the eccentricities that they indulge in. And we see them eat, we see them drink, we see them get married, we see them get divorced, we see them make jokes, take exercise or not take exercise, urinate, laugh at someone breaking wind, tying up their sandals, I mean all these kind of details. And I think that it's not just that it brings the Caesars alive, but
对几乎所有事情都本质上充满了迷恋。我的意思是，几乎没有任何细节是他不加探讨的。所以我们看到的凯撒们，更像是我们在政治背景下看到的当代政治家。所以我们看到他们，你知道，在与诸如公关丑闻、资金短缺或外交政策危机等问题搏斗。我们看到了他们的品味、他们的怪癖、他们沉溺的各种奇特行为。我们看到他们吃东西，看到他们喝酒，看到他们结婚，看到他们离婚，看到他们开玩笑，锻炼或不锻炼，排尿，嘲笑别人放屁，系鞋带，我的意思是所有这些细节。我认为这不仅让凯撒们变得鲜活，而且
it brings ancient Rome alive. Well, you made this point in your introduction. For people who are hesitating whether or not to buy your translation, I have to say it obviously pains me to say this, especially to say it publicly, but it's prefaced by a brilliant introduction by you. Oh, you're very kind Dominic. Where you explain all the context and whatnot. And you make the point that the pharaohs of Egypt or the great rulers of Persia, these people are just names really.
让古代罗马变得鲜活。嗯，你在引言中也提出了这一点。对于那些犹豫是否要买你的翻译的人，我必须说，说出这话显然让我感到痛苦，尤其是公开说出来，但它的前言是你写的一篇精彩的引言。哦，你太客气了，多米尼克。你在其中解释了所有的背景等等。你提出了这样一个观点：埃及的法老或波斯伟大的统治者，这些人其实只是一个个名字。
It's very hard for us to get a sense of their personalities, but thanks to Suetonius, you have a real sense. You know, you know what Augustus said. His appearance of modesty and simplicity. You know the tastes that Nero had. What clothes he wore. All of these kind of details that allow them to speak to us as flesh and blood, three dimensional characters in a way that's not really the case with any other people from, or very few
我们很难体会到他们的个性，但多亏了苏埃托尼乌斯，你有了真实的感觉。你知道，你知道奥古斯都说过什么。他那种谦逊和朴素的外表。你知道尼禄有什么样的品味。他穿什么衣服。所有这些细节使他们能够像有血有肉的三维人物一样与我们对话，而这在古代世界的其他人身上并不真正存在，或者极少在
other people from the ancient world. Yeah. And so it's often kind of assumed that our interest in ancient Rome over and above, say that of Egypt or Persia or whatever, is maybe because of Eurocentrism or whatever. But I truly think that it is simply because these rulers live more vividly than any other rulers in antiquity. And this is largely down to Suetonius. And you said that Suetonius is interested in violence. He is also of course massively interested in sex. And I would say that probably of all the things that Suetonius is known for, that is what he is probably, well, I mean, you
古代世界的其他人身上存在。是的。所以人们通常会认为，我们对古代罗马的兴趣超过了对埃及、波斯等地的兴趣，可能是因为欧洲中心主义之类的。但我真的认为，这仅仅是因为这些统治者比古代任何其他统治者都活得更加生动。这很大程度上要归功于苏埃托尼乌斯。你刚才说苏埃托尼乌斯对暴力感兴趣。当然，他对性也极其感兴趣。我想说，在苏埃托尼乌斯因之闻名的所有事情中，这可能就是他最，嗯，我的意思是，你
might say almost most notorious for. And the details that you get about the sex lives of the Caesars, I mean, it was capable of making the Romans themselves slightly go pale. So we have a poem that was written in the late fourth century, admittedly a time when the Roman elites were starting to become Christian. And this is by the poet Claudian. And he wrote about the early Caesars, the Caesars recorded in Suetonius' biographers, and he wrote, the stains of the crimes committed by the men of old, so that's the first Caesars, the twelve Caesars, will endure for all time. Condemnation will never be lacking of the monstrous deeds perpetrated by the house of
可以说几乎是声名狼藉的。关于凯撒们性生活的细节，我的意思是，它甚至能让罗马人自己感到微微脸红。所以我们有一首写于公元四世纪末的诗，诚然，当时罗马精英阶层开始成为基督徒。这是诗人克洛甸（Claudian）写的。他写到了早期的凯撒们，即苏埃托尼乌斯的传记中记载的凯撒们，他写道：古人所犯罪行的污点，也就是第一批凯撒，那十二位凯撒，将永远留存。对凯撒家族犯下的滔天罪行的谴责永远不会消失，
Caesar, Nero's unspeakable depravities, and those vile cliffs of Capri, the lair of an aged pervert. And that aged pervert, as you suggested already, is Tiberius who retires there and gets up to supposedly unspeakable things. And of course, we have mentioned Suetonius quite recently because we did a series on Charlemagne and Einhard, the great biographer of Charlemagne, is very influenced by Suetonius and models his biography of Charlemagne and Einhardt, the great biographer of Charlemagne, is very influenced by Suetonius and models his biography of Charlemagne on that of Augustus. So there's the sense in the Middle Ages that if you want to learn about how to exercise power, you do go to Suetonius, you read these biographies. But in the Middle Ages as well, there are people
尼禄无法言说的堕落，以及卡布里那些邪恶的悬崖，一个老变态的巢穴。而那个老变态，正如你刚才所暗示的，就是提比略，他在那里退隐并做出据说无法言说的行为。当然，我们最近提到了苏埃托尼乌斯，因为我们做了一个关于查理曼（Charlemagne）的系列节目，而查理曼伟大的传记作家艾因哈德（Einhard）深受苏埃托尼乌斯的影响，并以苏埃托尼乌斯为榜样来撰写他的查理曼传记，查理曼伟大的传记作家艾因哈德，深受苏埃托尼乌斯的影响，并以奥古斯都的传记为蓝本塑造他的查理曼传记。所以在中世纪，人们有一种感觉，如果你想学习如何行使权力，你确实会去读苏埃托尼乌斯，去读这些传记。但在中世纪，也有人
who are reading these lives to be titillated and shocked as well as to be inspired. And the most notorious example of someone who is influenced by what he reads in Suetonius to a repellent degree is a figure called Gilles de Rey, who in the 15th century is fighting the English in the Hundred Years' War, actually alongside Joan of Arc, it said. And he has read Suetonius and he reads about all these hideous crimes that Tiberius is supposed to have perpetrated against young children and ends up becoming a child killer and is hanged for this in 1440. And that's a kind of reflection of the kind of strange ambivalence of Suetonius' reputation. He's writing models for kings, but he's simultaneously inspiring unspeakable
为了寻求刺激和震惊，同时也为了获得启发而阅读这些生平。受苏埃托尼乌斯所读内容影响而达到令人厌恶程度的最臭名昭著的例子，是一个名叫吉尔·德·雷（Gilles de Rey）的人物。他在15世纪的百年战争中与英国人作战，据说实际上是与圣女贞德并肩作战。他读过苏埃托尼乌斯，读到提比略据称对儿童犯下的所有骇人听闻的罪行，最终自己也成了一个杀童犯，并于1440年因此被绞死。这某种程度上反映了苏埃托尼乌斯声誉中那种奇怪的矛盾性。他为国王撰写楷模，但同时又在启发着无法言说的
crimes. And this is a tension that runs throughout the Renaissance when he's a huge business. So you will get medallions, pictures, portraits, coins, the 12 Caesars throughout the Renaissance going into the Enlightenment. But at the same time, if you think of the Enlightenment, I mean, we did an episode on the Marquis de Sade. The Marquis de Sade, of course, has a copy of Suetonius in his library. And Dominic, we also did a series on public schools in the Victorian period. We did indeed. And the thing that I've always thought is mad about that is that Suetonius is a school
罪行。而这种紧张关系贯穿了整个文艺复兴时期，当时他非常受欢迎。所以你在整个文艺复兴时期直到启蒙运动，都会看到十二凯撒的奖章、图片、肖像和硬币。但与此同时，如果你想想启蒙运动，我的意思是，我们做过一期关于萨德侯爵（Marquis de Sade）的节目。萨德侯爵的图书馆里当然也有一本苏埃托尼乌斯。多米尼克，我们还做过一个关于维多利亚时代公立学校的系列节目。我们确实做过。而我一直认为这很疯狂的一点是，在受肌肉基督教影响的阿诺德博士（Dr. Arnold）管理的拉格比公学，苏埃托尼乌斯是男孩子们的一本学校
text for schoolboys at rugby under the muscularly Christian Dr. Arnold. And these boys are being given texts of Suetonius where the more dirty passages has asterisks. But of course, if they end up reading Latin very fluently, their privilege is that they can go and get the full Latin copy and read these disgusting accounts. So essentially, Dr. Arnold is training them to read about beastliness. There's quite a lot of beastliness in your translation, isn't there? Because obviously the first thing I did when I saw your translation was to check for all the beastly bits.
课本。这些男孩子拿到的是其中带有星号删节较脏段落的苏埃托尼乌斯文本。但当然，如果他们最终能非常流利地阅读拉丁语，他们的特权就是可以去找一本完整的拉丁语原本，去阅读这些令人作呕的记述。所以本质上，阿诺德博士是在训练他们阅读野蛮行径。你的译本里有相当多的野蛮行径，对吧？因为很显然，我看到你的译本时做的第一件事就是检查所有的野蛮片段。
And they're very much presently incorrect. You haven't gone for the asterisks. Though I have to say, you know, if there are people listening to this podcast with, you know, 10 year old children who love the Romans, this probably is not the ideal book because there's some quite pungent behaviour, isn't there? I think it's fair to say. Suetonius contains probably the most revolting passages in the whole of ancient literature. And I would guess if I say the single most revolting sentence, stuff that we don't want to repeat on this podcast. Okay.
而且它们非常真实，毫不避讳。你没有选择加星号。不过我必须说，你知道，如果这个播客的听众里有带着10岁、喜欢罗马历史的孩子的家长，这可能不是一本理想的书，因为里面有一些相当辛辣的行为，对吧？我认为这样说很公平。苏埃托尼乌斯包含的可能是整个古代文学中最令人作呕的段落。我猜，如果我说出那句最令人作呕的话，那些我们不想在这个播客里重复的内容。好吧。
But having said that, I would say that obviously today, throughout the 20th century, in fact, we've tended to pride ourselves on not being prudish in a kind of Victorian manner. You know, we don't put in the asterisks, I mean, I haven't in this translation. And there's a sense in which the themes of sex and violence in Suetonius have kind of come into their own in popular culture in the 20th century. And that's highlighted by the identity of the man who translated the previous edition of Suetonius' Lives for Penguin Classics, who's none other than Robert Graves. So the author of I, Claudius.
话虽如此，我想说，显然在今天，事实上在整个20世纪，我们倾向于以没有维多利亚式的虚伪而自豪。你知道，我们不加星号，我的意思是，我在这个翻译中没有加。某种程度上，苏埃托尼乌斯中性与暴力的主题在20世纪的大众文化中真正大放异彩。翻译了上一版企鹅经典版《苏埃托尼乌斯传记》的人的身份突显了这一点，他不是别人，正是罗伯特·格雷夫斯（Robert Graves）。也就是《我，克劳狄乌斯》（I, Claudius）的作者。
Yes. So Robert Graves obviously turned the raw material from the 12 Caesars into his novels, I, Claudius and Claudius the God. And I, Claudius then became a BBC TV series in the 1970s, hugely successful. And the appeal of it, I guess, both in I, Claudius and actually in Suetonius' original, it's got a little bit of the soap opera about it, hasn't it? The sex and the violence, the narrative twists, the melodrama, because it is a family, certainly the first few lives are a family melodrama, the family of Augustus and the crazy things that happen.
是的。所以罗伯特·格雷夫斯显然把《十二帝王传》中的原始素材变成了他的小说《我，克劳狄乌斯》和《克劳狄乌斯神》（Claudius the God）。而《我，克劳狄乌斯》在20世纪70年代成为了英国广播公司（BBC）的电视剧，取得了巨大的成功。它的吸引力，我猜，无论是在《我，克劳狄乌斯》还是在苏埃托尼乌斯的原文中，都带有那么一点肥皂剧的味道，对吧？性和暴力、叙事转折、情节剧，因为它确实是一个家族，前几篇传记绝对是一个家族情节剧，奥古斯都的家族以及发生的那些疯狂的事情。
Yeah. You have the figure of Augustus who's the kind of patriarch. You have a murderous competition to succeed him. In the figure of Livia, Augustus's wife, as reworked by Robert Graves. You have the kind of the ultimate homicidal matriarch, and you have Claudius who survives the terrifying reigns of Tiberius and Caligula, and it ends with him as emperor, so he seems to be triumphant. But in the final pages of the novel and the final episode of the series, you have the encroaching shadow of the reign of Nero as it comes. And there are so many elements of that, that then feeds into TV drama through the 80s and
是的。你有奥古斯都这个大家长式的人物。为了继承他，存在着一场充满谋杀的竞争。在罗伯特·格雷夫斯重新塑造的奥古斯都妻子莉薇娅（Livia）身上。你拥有了某种终极的谋杀成性的女家长，而克劳狄乌斯在提比略和卡利古拉恐怖的统治下幸存下来，最终以皇帝身份结束，所以他似乎获得了胜利。但在小说的最后几页和剧集的最后一集，你迎面感受到了即将到来的尼禄统治的阴影。这其中有许多元素，随后一直延续到80年代及
later. So in the United States, the soap opera dynasty with Joan Collins. You've said it in the American way, Tom. You've absolutely shamed yourself. Yeah. Lots of shoulder pads and kind of lip gloss. It's all set in, I think, in Denver, isn't it? Very clearly modeled on I, Claudius.
以后的电视剧中。所以在美国，有由琼·柯林斯（Joan Collins）主演的肥皂剧《豪门恩怨》（Dynasty）。你用了美式发音，汤姆。你彻底丢脸了。是的。大量的垫肩和唇彩。它好像背景设在丹佛，对吧？很明显是以《我，克劳狄乌斯》为蓝本的。
But then in the late nineties, going into the early 21st century, there's a series that is even more influential and even more obviously influenced by I, Claudius. Very overtly so, in fact, and that's the Sopranos. So there is an episode in which Tony Soprano sits on the bleachers at a baseball game and discusses Augustus and says of his reign, it was the longest time of peace in Rome's history. He was a fair leader and all his people loved him for that. Yeah, he identifies with him, doesn't he? Yeah, he does. Although actually, Tony Soprano's mother is called Livia as Tiberius' was, so there's
但在90年代末到21世纪初，有一部剧集更具影响力，并且更明显地受到《我，克劳狄乌斯》的影响。事实上非常明显，那就是《黑道家族》（The Sopranos）。其中有一集，托尼·索普拉诺（Tony Soprano）坐在棒球比赛的看台上讨论奥古斯都，并谈到他的统治时说，这是罗马历史上最长的和平时期。他是一个公正的领袖，他的人民都为此爱戴他。是的，他认同他，对吧？是的，他确实认同。尽管事实上，托尼·索普拉诺的母亲叫莉薇娅，就像提比略的母亲一样，所以
a slight element in which he's Tiberius as well as Augustus. And it works brilliantly because, of course, the power of the Caesars is founded on muscle, on intimidation. And if you think of Augustus as a kind of godfather figure with a family, I mean that maps on very well onto what's happening with the Sopranos and then the Sopranos in turn of course influences Game of Thrones or whatever and although Game of Thrones is clearly drawing on specific episodes in medieval history, the overarching idea of a wrestling for power with poison and incest and dynastic feuding. Again, the wellsprings for this, I think, are I, Claudius. I always wondered, so the
在某种程度上，他既是提比略也是奥古斯都。这效果非常绝妙，因为当然，凯撒们的权力是建立在武力和恐吓之上的。如果你把奥古斯都想象成一个带着家族的教父式人物，我的意思是，这与《黑道家族》中发生的事情非常吻合，而《黑道家族》反过来又影响了《权力的游戏》等等，尽管《权力的游戏》显然借鉴了中世纪历史上的具体情节，但争夺权力、充满毒药、乱伦和王朝争斗的总体构想。同样，这一切的源泉，我认为，就是《我，克劳狄乌斯》。我一直在想，扮演乔佛里（Joffrey）——那个有点像卡利古拉式国王的演员杰克·格里森（Jack Gleeson）。我的意思是，他长得就像卡利古拉。如果你见过卡利古拉的肖像半身像，我一直想知道这是否是刻意的。谈到戏剧性这一点，你在新译本的引言中详细谈到了这一点。
Jack Gleeson, the actor who played Joffrey, the kind of Caligula type king. I mean, he looks like Caligula. If you've ever seen the kind of portrait bust of Caligula, I always wondered whether that was kind of deliberate. So to go to this thing about there being a drama, you make this point at some length, you talk about this in your introduction to the new translation. And also to pick up your point about Augustus being the godfather, you make the point that Augustus from the very beginning, arguably his greatest political skill, is that he's brilliant at playing lots of different parts and he has lots of different kind of masks and personas. And you describe him as Rome's greatest actor.
并且为了呼应你关于奥古斯都是教父的观点，你指出奥古斯都从一开始，可以说他最伟大的政治技巧就是他非常擅长扮演许多不同的角色，并且他拥有许多不同的面具和人格。你把他描述为罗马最伟大的演员。
And there's this very, very famous scene, which is from Suetonius, where Augustus is on his death bed and he has himself all kind of primped and whatnot, he does his hair and he, he has his jaw set straight. And then he had sort of his friends in and he says to them, do you think I played my part in the comedy of life? Well, and then he says, he quotes lines from a play, if the play has been a good one, clap your hands and let me leave the stage to the sound of your applause. It's a brilliant, brilliant ending. If it really happened, I
有一个非常非常著名的场景，出自苏埃托尼乌斯，奥古斯都临终时，他让人把自己的仪容打扮得妥妥当当，梳理了头发，并让下巴保持笔直。然后他让朋友们进来，对他们说：“你们觉得我在人生这场喜剧中演好我的角色了吗？”嗯，然后他说，他引用了一句戏剧台词：“如果这场戏演得好，请鼓掌，让我伴随着你们的掌声离开舞台。”这是一个非常非常精彩的结局。如果这真的发生了，
mean, who knows whether it happened or whether it's a folk tale that was told about Augustus. But even if it didn't happen, I mean, it's telling that that story should have been told about him. It seems appropriate and fitting. So this idea of the Caesars as actors, that kind of runs through Sueternius, doesn't it? That they're playing parts on a stage. Yeah. And again, it's why Augustus is the exemplar. So Augustus in a way is the kind of centre of the collection of biographies. It's by far the longest, the most sophisticated, the most complex of the biographies. And one of the ways in which it sets the template is that, as you said, Augustus is the model of how to be a Caesar because he is also the model
我的意思是，谁知道它是否真的发生过，还是关于奥古斯都的民间传说。但即使它没有发生，这个故事被流传下来本身也很说明问题。它显得既恰当又贴切。所以这种把凯撒视为演员的想法，贯穿了苏埃托尼乌斯的作品，对吧？他们是在舞台上扮演角色。是的。这也是为什么奥古斯都是典范。所以在某种程度上，奥古斯都是这本传记合集的核心。它是所有传记中最长、最成熟、最复杂的。它确立模板的方式之一就是，正如你所说，奥古斯都是如何成为一个凯撒的楷模，因为他同时也是
of how to be an actor. And his ability to play all the roles that Caesar has to play is kind of portrayed by Suetonius as being key to his success. So this is evident in, well kind of in the range of names that he has throughout his life. So he begins as Gaius Octavius, then he's adopted as Julius Caesar's heir, so he becomes Julius Caesar. Then he's given the name Augustus. Suetonius tells us that when he stamps official documents, Augustus uses a seal that is decorated with a sphinx, so very practiced at telling riddles. And over the course of his life, he picks up masks and then lays them down as circumstances require. So as a young man, it's his mission to avenge his murdered adoptive
关于如何成为一名演员。苏维托尼乌斯将他扮演凯撒所需扮演的所有角色的能力，描绘成他成功的关键。这一点很明显，嗯，从他一生中所拥有的名字的变化中就可以看出。他最初叫盖乌斯·屋大维，后来被收养为尤利乌斯·凯撒的继承人，于是他变成了尤利乌斯·凯撒。后来他又被赐名为奥古斯都。苏维托尼乌斯告诉我们，奥古斯都在盖官方文件时，使用的是一枚刻有狮身人面像的印章，因此他非常擅长讲谜语。在他人生的历程中，随着环境的需要，他不断地拿起面具，然后又放下。所以当他还是个年轻人时，他的使命就是为他被谋杀的养
father, Julius Caesar, and he consciously practices terrorism to do that. He makes his name one that would chill even the highest ranking nobleman in Rome. So Suetonius describes one incident. It is claimed by some authors that on the Ides of March, so that's the anniversary of Caesar's murder, he selected 300 senators and knights from among those who had surrendered and had them butchered like sacrificial animals on an altar dedicated to Julius Caesar. So, Suetonius is upfront about that, even though he greatly admires Augustus. But ultimately, the reason that he admires Augustus isn't because he is a kind of murderous vigilante wiping out the assassins of his adoptive father, but because having done that, he gives the Roman people
父尤利乌斯·凯撒复仇，为此他有意地实行恐怖主义。他让自己的名字成为罗马最高贵族都会感到不寒而栗的名字。苏维托尼乌斯描述了一起事件。一些作家声称，在三月节那天，也就是凯撒遇刺的周年纪念日，他从投降的人中挑选了300名元老和骑士，并在献给尤利乌斯·凯撒的祭坛上像宰杀祭牲一样把他们屠杀。因此，苏维托尼乌斯对此直言不讳，尽管他非常崇拜奥古斯都。但归根结底，他崇拜奥古斯都的原因并不是因为他是一个四处消灭养父刺客的嗜血义警，而是因为在做了这些之后，他给了罗马人民
what they have not had for many decades, namely peace. And he lives so long that he comes to serve the Romans as their father. And Suetonius sees this as an achievement that is genuinely, literally, more than human. The word Augustus means more than human, kind of halfway to the divine. And when he comes to the end of his biography, Suetonius writes, perhaps it will not be off topic to include here an account of everything that happened prior to his birth, Augustus's birth, on the actual day of his nativity and then subsequent to it, which served to portend his future greatness and to offer the hope of good fortune without end. And it's in the reign of Augustus that Jesus is born. And the echo of the stories that are told by Christians about the nativity of Jesus and about the
他们几十年来未曾拥有过的东西，即和平。而且他活了那么久，以至于成为了罗马人的父亲。苏维托尼乌斯认为这是一项真正意义上超越人类的成就。奥古斯都这个词的意思就是超越人类，可以说是半神半人。当他写到传记的结尾时，苏维托尼乌斯写道，在这里顺便记述在他出生之前，也就是奥古斯都出生之前，在他出生的那一天以及之后发生的一切，可能并非题外话，这些事情预示了他未来的伟大，并带来了永无止境的好运。正是在奥古斯都在位期间，耶稣诞生了。基督徒讲述的关于耶稣诞生以及关于
prophecies that were told about his coming are very, very redolent of the stories that Suetonius gives about the birth of Augustus. And I think it's a crucial part of the biographies that even though you are getting details about urination and farts and all that kind of stuff, you are also getting a sense that this extraordinary drama, these extraordinary lives exist in the context of the supernatural. When Julius Caesar crosses the Rubicon, a mysterious spirit blows a trumpet. The ghost of Caesar is seen on kind of lonely paths. Omens and portents shadow the lives of the Caesars right the way through. And that too is a part of the story. And that's what makes Augustus' achievement as an actor who stands on the stage of the
关于他降临的预言的故事，与苏维托尼乌斯讲述的奥古斯都出生时的故事有着非常强烈的相似之处。我认为传记中至关重要的一点是，尽管你得到了关于排尿、放屁以及诸如此类琐事的细节，但你也感受到这种非凡的戏剧性、这些非凡的人生是存在于超自然背景之中的。当尤利乌斯·凯撒跨越卢比孔河时，一个神秘的幽灵吹响了号角。凯撒的幽灵在荒凉的小路上被人看到。预兆和凶兆一直伴随着凯撒们的一生。这也是故事的一部分。这就是奥古斯都作为一名站在世界舞台上的演员所取得的成就
world. He's also standing on the stage of the heavens and in his death will become a god. That thing about Augustus as an actor, this is also a brilliant kind of primer in politics and how politics works. And politics as something that actually, you know, Donald Trump instinctively knows and Keir Starmer doesn't, which is that politics is about performance and about display and ritual and so on. And show business, I guess, to an extent.
他同时也站在了天堂的舞台上，并且在他死后将成为神。关于奥古斯都作为演员的这一点，这也是一本关于政治以及政治如何运作的绝佳入门书。政治实际上，你知道的，唐纳德·特朗普凭直觉就懂，而基尔·斯塔默却不懂，那就是政治是关于表演、展示、仪式等等的。某种程度上，也可以说是一门演艺事业。
And Suetonius is brilliant on politics as show business. That runs right through the 12 biographies, doesn't it? Absolutely. And it highlights something that makes the Caesars distinctive among the autocrats of antiquity, which is that they are expected to put themselves up before the mass of the people. They are expected to stage entertainments and shows and kind of gladiatorial combats, which means that if they are unpopular, they will be booed. So it's a constant process of testing your popularity. And that, I think, is why Suetonius is so interested in things like gladiatorial combats, the details of beast hunts and things like that. It's not just the show itself.
苏维托尼乌斯对将政治视作演艺事业的看法真是精辟极了。这贯穿了全部12部传记，不是吗？绝对是的。而且它突显了凯撒们在古代专制君主中独一无二的一个特点，那就是他们被期望将自己展现给广大民众。他们被期望筹办娱乐活动、表演以及角斗士比赛，这意味着如果他们不受欢迎，就会遭到嘘声。所以这是一个不断考验你受欢迎程度的过程。我认为，这就是为什么苏维托尼乌斯对角斗士比赛、兽猎活动的细节等事物如此感兴趣的原因。这不仅仅是因为表演本身。
It's the fact that being able to put on a show, it's a crucial part of what it is to be a good emperor. And obviously Augustus establishes the template for what it is to be a good emperor and to some extent, I guess you could argue the story of Sotenius' book is the story of people struggling to fill his shoes. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. Yeah. Definitely the case of Tiberius, I guess, with Achilla, Gila and Claudius
而是因为能够举办一场表演，是成为一个好皇帝至关重要的一部分。显然，奥古斯都为如何成为一个好皇帝树立了样板，在某种程度上，我想你可以争辩说，苏维托尼乌斯这本书的故事就是人们挣扎着想要继承他的衣钵的故事。是的，我想这绝对是对的。是的。提比略肯定也是这样，我猜，还有卡利古拉和克劳狄乌斯
in the initial successes, they're all part of his family. I mean, this is the remarkable thing, isn't it? That it's a kind of monarchy in all but name. Yeah. At first purely for dynastic reasons, not because they've won power. Well, Tiberius is a very accomplished man. The others are not so accomplished, but as long as that family endures, which it does to the time of Nero, the line of succession is kind of, it kind of makes some sense. But when Nero is killed, and then you have the year of the
在最初的成功中，他们都是他家族的一部分。我的意思是，这是一件很 remarquable 的事情，不是吗？这就是一个名副其实的君主国。是的。起初纯粹出于王朝的原因，而不是因为他们赢得了权力。嗯，提比略是一个非常有才华的人。其他人没有那么有才华，但只要那个家族能够延续下去，一直延续到尼禄时期，继承线就某种程度上说，某种程度上还算说得通。但是当尼禄被杀死，然后你经历了
four emperors and then the rise of the Flavian dynasty, how do they see themselves in terms of their succession from, I mean, they're still trying to become Augustus, aren't they? Yeah. So as you say, I think Augustus is at the heart of it. And then the emperors who belong to his family, the house of Caesar, they're kind of, you know, the next ring. And then on the outer ring, you have the biographies of figures who provide a different perspective on the course of Roman history. So if you look backwards from Augustus, you have the first of the 12 Caesars, who, as you said, isn't an emperor at all, and that's Julius Caesar. And that serves as a reminder to the reader that there is a world
四帝之年，接着是弗拉维王朝的崛起，他们如何看待自己相对于——我的意思是，他们仍然试图成为奥古斯都，不是吗？是的。正如你所说，我认为奥古斯都处于核心地位。然后属于他家族的皇帝们，即凯撒家族，他们算是，你知道的，外围的一圈。再往外一层，你就会看到那些为罗马历史进程提供不同视角的人物传记。所以如果你从奥古斯都倒回去看，你会看到12位凯撒中的第一位，正如你所说，他根本不是一个皇帝，那就是尤利乌斯·凯撒。这提醒了读者，还有一个世界
that is less claustrophobic than that of the autocracy introduced by Augustus because Caesar is operating in a republic with the lives of the emperors. There's the sense that the emperor is at the heart of the state. Julius Caesar is a man of incredible accomplishment, but he is just one of a multitude of power players. In a very chaotic, very chaotic world. Yeah, in the drama of his age. And Suetonius judges him by the standards of that age. So he really admires Julius Caesar. He recognizes that Caesar is an extraordinary genius, a
比起奥古斯都引入的专制统治，这个世界没有那么令人窒息，因为凯撒是在一个共和国中运作的，而伴随着皇帝们的生活，你会有一种皇帝处于国家核心的感觉。尤利乌斯·凯撒是一个才华横溢的人，但他只是众多权力玩家中的一员。在一个非常混乱、非常混乱的世界里。是的，在他那个时代的戏剧中。苏维托尼乌斯用那个时代的标准来评判他。所以他真的很崇拜尤利乌斯·凯撒。他承认凯撒是一个非凡的天才，一个
great general, a great orator, a great writer. He's a brilliant urban planning. I mean, drawing up calendars is almost nothing he can't do. And also he's a man of great mercy. He pardons his defeated enemies. But in the buildup to his account of the murder of Caesar in the eyes of March, he judges the reckoning must still be that Caesar abused his position of power and deserved to be slain. So that's a kind of fascinating perspective that the reader can then take into the lives of the subsequent Caesars. Yeah, given that they are autocrats and Julius Caesar kind of wasn't.
伟大的将领，伟大的演说家，伟大的作家。他是一位杰出的城市规划师。我的意思是，制定历法几乎没有什么事情是他做不到的。而且他也是一个非常仁慈的人。他宽恕了他被击败的敌人。但在他记述凯撒在三月节遇刺的铺垫中，他认为必须得出的结论仍然是：凯撒滥用了他的权力地位，罪有应得。因此，这是一个引人入胜的视角，读者随后可以将其带入对后来的凯撒们一生的阅读中。是的，鉴于他们是专制君主，而尤利乌斯·凯撒某种程度上算不上。
Right, exactly. So that's one thing that frames the life of Augustus and the emperors who belong to the house of Caesar. But then the other thing is what succeeds him. So when Nero dies, he's succeeded by this guy called Galba, who like Julius Caesar is a man from a kind of ancient Republican dynasty. He's a reminder of an age that preceded the coming to power of Augustus. But the thing is, he has no conceivable link to the divine family of the first emperor. He sees his power because he has the armies and the backing that enable him to do it. And it's because of that, that he doesn't really have sufficient authority to maintain his rule and therefore his life. As a Caesar,
对，没错。所以这是构筑奥古斯都以及属于凯撒家族的皇帝们生平的背景之一。但另一件事是继承他的人。因此，当尼禄死后，继承他的是一个叫加尔巴的人，他像尤利乌斯·凯撒一样，出身于一个古老的共和派王朝。他是奥古斯都掌权之前那个时代的提醒。但问题是，他与第一位皇帝的神圣家族没有任何可联系的纽带。他夺取权力是因为他拥有军队以及支持他这样做的后盾。正因为如此，他并没有足够的权威来维持他的统治，从而也无法维持他的生命。作为一个凯撒，
if you're unable to rule, then you're going to die. So Galbar his life. As a Caesar, if you're unable to rule then you're going to die. So Galbar is succeeded by Otho, by Vitellius, by Vespasian. Vespasian survives, founds this dynasty, succeeded by his sons Titus and Domitian. And you have six biographies following Nero in all. And I think all of these in comparison to the biographies of the emperors who are succeeding Augustus, they kind of feel a bit slight, a bit attenuated. And these emperors are less terrible than Caligula or Nero, but they're also kind of less awesome. So the family of Augustus, the family of Julius Caesar, they claim descent from Venus, the goddess
如果你无力统治，那么你就会死。因此，加尔巴死后，奥托、维特利亚斯、韦斯帕西安相继继位。韦斯帕西安幸存下来，开创了这个王朝，随后由他的儿子提图斯和图密善继位。尼禄之后总共有六部传记。我认为所有这些传记，与那些继奥古斯都之后的皇帝的传记相比，都显得有点单薄，有点逊色。这些皇帝没有卡利古拉或尼禄那么可怕，但他们在某种程度上也显得不那么令人敬畏。所以奥古斯都家族，尤利乌斯·凯撒家族，他们宣称自己是维纳斯女神的后代
Venus. The house of Aspasian, they have descent from a bailiff. And that essentially is telling you about the diminished character of the age. The sense that an emperor is properly part of a kind of almost a mythological world has pretty much gone. And when Demission dies, Demission is assassinated, and he's not assassinated as Caesar was by his peers, by his senators, but by Friedman in a kind of squalid scuffle in the palace, his memory is completely erased. Except of course it isn't erased because Suetonius is telling us this in his biography. But he ends Domitian's biography and therefore all the lives of the Caesars with this passage.
维纳斯。韦斯帕西安家族，他们的祖先是一个管家。这实际上向你讲述了这个时代特质的衰退。皇帝本应神话般世界的一部分这种感觉几乎已经消失了。当图密善死去时，图密善被暗杀了，他不像凯撒那样被同僚、被元老院成员暗杀，而是在皇宫里的一场肮脏混战中被解放奴隶暗杀了，他的记忆被彻底抹去了。当然，除了并没有被完全抹去，因为苏维托尼乌斯正在他的传记中讲述这一切。但他以这段话结束了图密善的传记，从而也结束了所有凯撒的生平。
Even Domitian himself, they say, when he dreamed that a hump of gold sprouted out of his back, interpreted this as a sure sign that the Republic was destined to enjoy happier and more prosperous times once he had gone. And sure enough, thanks to the measured and moderate behavior displayed by the emperors who followed him, so it rapidly came to pass. So here is a further sense in which the terrifying age of crime and bloodshed and sexual extravagance is fading away because Suetonius is situating himself in an age of measured and moderate emperors. Yeah. This is the age in which he is writing. So a slightly quieter age, I guess, but, but without the excitement and the histrionics of the first Caesar.
据说，甚至图密善本人，当他梦见背上长出一个肉瘤时，将其解释为一旦他离去，共和国必将迎来更加幸福和繁荣时期的确凿迹象。果不其然，由于他之后的皇帝们所表现出的克制和温和的行为，这一切很快就实现了。因此，这里还有另一种感觉，即充满犯罪、流血和穷奢极欲的可怕时代正在消逝，因为苏维托尼乌斯将自己置于一个由克制和温和的皇帝统治的时代。是的。这就是他写作的时代。所以我想这是一个稍微安静一点的时代，但是，却没有第一位凯撒时期的兴奋和戏剧性。
Yes. Now, by the way, listeners who are interested in those first Caesar's, we have three episodes to come on Tiberius, Caligula and Claudius. And obviously if you remember the Rest the history club, you can hear those straight after this, but we will be back after the break to hear about Suetonius himself, because this is a fascinating story about the man who wrote these biographies, and actually the man from whom we derive so much of our understanding of the early Roman Empire.
是的。顺便说一下，对那些第一位凯撒们感兴趣的听众，我们还有三集关于提比略、卡利古拉和克劳狄乌斯的节目。显然，如果你是“重回历史”俱乐部的会员，你可以在这之后立即收听这些节目，但我们在休息之后会回来讲述苏维托尼乌斯本人，因为这是一个关于撰写这些传记的人的迷人故事，也是一个关于我们如何理解早期罗马帝国的许多知识之源的故事。
So we're back after the break. Roman Empire. So we're back after the break. As a boy, I obtained a small bust of Augustus, an old bronze which had the name Thurinus, inscribed on it in letters of iron, albeit almost faded away. I made a gift of this statuette to the Emperor who now keeps it in his private chamber as an object of reverence." So this comes from Suetonius' biography of Augustus. Suetonius is of course talking about himself and it's a very rare glimpse of the author himself. He's telling you a little detail about the statue that he gave to the Emperor as we will
休息过后我们回来了。罗马帝国。休息过后我们回来了。作为一个男孩，我得到了一尊奥古斯都的小半身像，这是一件古老的青铜器，上面用铁字刻着“图里努斯”的名字，虽然已经几乎褪色了。我把这尊小雕像送给了皇帝，他现在把它放在自己的私人寝室里作为崇拜的对象。”这段话出自苏埃托尼乌斯写的奥古斯都传记。苏埃托尼乌斯当然是在谈论他自己，这是一个非常罕见的窥见作者本人的机会。他向你讲述了关于他送给皇帝的那座雕像的一个小细节，正如我们等一下会
discover the Emperor is Hadrian. So Tom, unpack this a little detail about the statue that he gave to the emperor, as we will discover the emperor is Hadrian. So Tom, unpack this a little bit for us. Yeah, I think it's rare, it's precious, and it's fascinating because it kind of highlights, I suppose two things. Firstly, Suetonius' methods. So this is in the context of a debate that Suetonius is having with kind of unnamed critics about whether the name Therinus had been one of the names adopted by Augustus. Suetonius thinks it was, his critics think that it wasn't. And he's offering the fact that this bust
发现的，这位皇帝就是哈德良。所以，汤姆，请给我们稍微剖析一下他送给皇帝的这座雕像的小细节，正如我们等一下会发现的，这位皇帝就是哈德良。汤姆，请为我们稍微展开讲讲。是的，我认为这很罕见，很珍贵，也很迷人，因为它在某种程度上突出了，我想是两点。首先，苏埃托尼乌斯的方法。所以这是在一个背景下，苏埃托尼乌斯正在与一些无名批评家进行辩论，关于“图里努斯”这个名字是否曾是被奥古斯都采用的名字之一。苏埃托尼乌斯认为是，他的批评家们认为不是。而他把这尊
existed with the word Therinus on it as evidence. And it demonstrates the way in which Suetonius is a proper scholar. He does his research. He compiles evidence. But it's also fascinating because it illustrates that he knows what he's talking about when he discusses the Caesars and the court of the Caesars, because he is clearly very close to the emperor. If he can give to Hadrian, you know, a portrait bust that he's found, that suggests a real degree of intimacy. And it's evident both from Suetonius' biographies,
刻有“图里努斯”一词的半身像的存在作为证据提出来。这展示了苏埃托尼乌斯作为一个真正的学者的行事方式。他做研究。他搜集证据。但这也同样迷人，因为它表明，当他讨论凯撒大帝和凯撒的宫廷时，他是知道自己在谈论什么的，因为他显然与皇帝非常亲近。如果他能送给哈德良，你知道的，一个他找到的肖像半身像，这暗示了真正程度上的亲密。这从苏埃托尼乌斯的传记中可以明显看出，
but also from all the evidence that we have from the Roman world, that power in antiquity in the Roman Empire depends on proximity to Caesar. And Suetonius clearly has that. He is a man who's operating at the absolute heart of the imperial administration. He knows what he is talking about. So what else do we know about him? So do we have any sense, for example, of when he might have been born or where his family came from? So there are other details that are scattered through the lives of the Caesar. So we know that his grandfather had
而且从我们拥有的来自罗马世界的所有证据中也可以看出，古代罗马帝国的权力取决于与凯撒的亲疏关系。而苏埃托尼乌斯显然拥有这种关系。他是一个在帝国行政管理核心部门运作的人。他很清楚自己在谈论什么。那么，关于他，我们还知道些什么呢？比如，对于他可能出生于何时或他的家族来自哪里，我们有什么头绪吗？在凯撒们的生平中还散落着其他细节。所以我们知道他的祖父曾经
watched Caligula when he built the great bridge of boats and rode across the Bay of Naples to and fro on a chariot. We know that his father had been with Otho in the civil war that Otho had fought against Fertelius, his army gets defeated, Otho commits suicide. Suetonius's father had been in Otho's camp when that happened. And he personally bears witness to the campaign of taxation that Domitian and the Flavians generally, the family of Domitian had conducted against the Judeans. So Vespasian and Titus had conquered Judea and had then imposed a tax on the Judeans, which required them to pay money that had previously gone to the temple in Jerusalem to the restoration of the temple of Jupiter in the heart of Rome.
观看过卡利古拉建造伟大的船桥，并乘战车在 那不勒斯湾来回驰骋。我们知道他的父亲曾在内战中跟随奥托，那是奥托与维特利乌斯作战的一场战争，他的军队被击败，奥托自杀。当这一切发生时，苏埃托尼乌斯的父亲就在奥托的阵营里。并且他亲眼见证了图密善和弗拉维王朝普遍而言，即图密善的家族对犹太人实施的征税运动。因此，韦斯帕赞和提图斯征服了犹太地，然后对犹太人强加了一项税收，这要求他们把以前交给耶路撒冷圣殿的钱，用来修复罗马市中心的朱庇特神庙。
And of course, there were Judeans who tried to get out of this. And Suetonius describes Domitian's determination not to let these tax evaders get away with it. And he writes, he gave no quarter to those who pretended not to be Judean in an attempt to avoid paying the tribute levied on their nation. Indeed, and this is the personal note, I remember as a young man being present in a very crowded court when an old man who was 90 years old had his penis inspected by a financial official to see if he had been circumcised. Okay. That's a strange memory.
当然，也有犹太人试图逃避这笔税。苏埃托尼乌斯描述了图密善不让这些逃税者漏网的坚定决心。他写道：“对于那些假装自己不是犹太人以图逃避对其民族征收的赋税的人，他毫不手软。”确实，这就是个人的记录，“我记得年轻时曾在一个非常拥挤的法庭上在场，当时有一位九十岁的老人被财政官员检查了阴茎，看看他是否受过割礼。”好吧。这是一个奇怪的记忆。
Isn't it? I mean, incredible detail to have, kind of very vivid and strange. And people have kind of played with that to go backwards, say, well, if he's a young man then then he was probably born round about the time of the death of Nero. Because that would place him as a very young man, you know, during the reign of Domitian and Domitian's campaign against the tax evaders and so on and so forth. And he's from North Africa. Is that right? Is what his family are from North Africa originally?
不是吗？我的意思是，拥有如此不可思议的细节，既非常生动又很诡异。人们曾某种程度上利用这一点来进行推算，说，好吧，如果他当时是个年轻的话，那他大概出生在尼禄死后不久。因为这将使他在图密善统治期间以及图密善针对逃税者的运动等等时期成为一个非常年轻的人。而且他来自北非，对吗？他的家族原本是来自北非吗？
That seems to be the implication of an inscription that was found in 1952 in ruins of a city called Hipporegius. So that's actually the city which in due course, St. Augustine would become the bishop of. Oh, right. Yeah. And it suggests that Suetonius's family had originally come from there. But I mean, if so, there's no evidence really of any kind of particular stake in North Africa from Suetonius' writing. His focus is very much on Italy and Rome and that seems to be where he grew up. And we also know from the letters of Pliny
这似乎是1952年在名为希波雷吉乌斯（Hipporegius）的一座城市的废墟中发现的一块铭文所暗示的。所以这实际上就是圣奥古斯丁日后将成为其主教的那座城市。哦，对的。是的。这表明苏埃托尼乌斯的家族最初来自那里。但我的意思是，如果是这样的话，从苏埃托尼乌斯的著作中确实没有任何证据表明他在北非有任何特殊的利益。他的焦点很大程度上在意大利和罗马，那似乎是他长大成人的地方。我们从小普林尼的信件中也知道这一点，
the Younger, the guy who gives us two brilliant accounts of the eruption of Vesuvius that destroys Pompeii and Herculaneum, that Suetonius is part of Pliny the Younger's set. It's a kind of a literary set. It's a set in which Pliny the Younger will advance kind of able younger people like Suetonius who could benefit from his patronage. And we know actually that Pliny the Younger seems to have obtained a post for Suetonius in Britain, which Suetonius then turned down. And there is an intriguing detail that in 1973 in Vindolanda, so the fort just south of what would become Hadrian's Wall, there was a letter found there detailing the contents of a trunk that had been sent by someone called Tranquilus. And that of course is one of Suetonius' names.
小普林尼，也就是那个为我们提供关于摧毁庞贝和赫库兰尼姆的维苏威火山爆发的两个精彩记述的人，苏埃托尼乌斯是小普林尼朋友圈子的一部分。这是一个文学圈子。在这个圈子里，小普林尼会提携像苏埃托尼乌斯这样能够从他的庇护中受益的有能力的年轻人。我们其实知道，小普林尼似乎曾为苏埃托尼乌斯在不列颠争取到一个职位，但苏埃托尼乌斯随后拒绝了。并且有一个耐人寻味的细节，在1973年的文多兰达（Vindolanda），也就是日后哈德良长城以南不远的那个堡垒，人们在那里发现了一信件，详尽列出了一个由一个叫特兰奎吕斯（Tranquillus）的人所寄出的一个大箱子的物品。这当然就是苏埃托尼乌斯的名字之一。
And the great scholar, Anthony Burley, who had actually excavated at Vindolanda, he kind of pondered whether this had actually been Suetonius' kit, so he wrote, "'Is it possible that Suetonius had had a box of his gear, including blankets, dining outfits, and vests sent ahead to Britain?' I mean, it'd be wonderful to think that he
伟大的学者安东尼·伯利（Anthony Birley）曾在文多兰达进行过发掘，他曾思索这是否真的是苏埃托尼乌斯的行装，所以他写道：“苏埃托尼乌斯有没有可能把一箱他的装备，包括毯子、餐饮用具和背心，提前寄往不列颠呢？”我的意思是，如果他真的这样做过，那将是一件很棒的事。
had. But luckily for Suetonius, he doesn't end up in the North of England. In Vindolanda. He ends up working very closely in the Imperial Archive. Is that right? So in Rome, in the libraries in Rome. Yeah. So first the Imperial Archives, then the Roman libraries, and then under Hadrian, he becomes what was called the ab epistulis, which essentially is his kind of senior secretary, the guy who handles his correspondence. And that means that there is no letter that comes to Hadrian or goes from Hadrian that Suetonius has not
但对苏埃托尼乌斯来说幸运的是，他并没有在英格兰北部结束他的旅程。在文多兰达。他最终在帝国档案室里非常紧密地工作。是这样的吗？所以在罗马，在罗马的图书馆里。是的。所以先是帝国档案室，然后是罗马图书馆，接着在哈德良手下，他成为了所谓的“掌信官”（ab epistulis），这本质上就是他的高级秘书，那个处理他信件的人。这意味着，没有任何一封寄给哈德良或由哈德良发出的信件是苏埃托尼乌斯没有
handled. And it means that for the term of his office, he is one of the most important functionaries in the whole of the empire. And this must explain his ready access to all the historical documents that he is citing in the biographies. And he probably obtained this not from Pliny the Younger, because by this point Pliny seems to have died, but by another patron who is a guy called Septicius Clarus, who is the dedicatii of the lives of the Caesars and who has become the chief of the Praetorians. So probably the most significant imperial servant in the whole of the empire because he's responsible for the emperor's security. But this is a problem, isn't it, in the long run, because in 122, so this is the thing
经手过的。这意味着在他任职期间，他是整个帝国最重要的官员之一。这一定能解释他为什么能随时查阅他在传记中所引用的所有历史文献。他大概不是从小普林尼那里得到这个职位的，因为到这个时候小普林尼似乎已经去世了，而是通过另一个庇护人，一个名叫塞普蒂丘斯·克拉鲁斯（Septicius Clarus）的人，他正是《凯撒传》的献祭对象，后来成为了禁卫军长官。所以他可能是整个帝国中最重要的帝国官员，因为他负责皇帝的安全。但这从长远来看是个问题，不是吗？因为在122年，这就是
about going to Britain, you should basically never go to Britain because Suetonius and Septicius, Clarus gone to Britain as well with Hadrian. Yes, of course, because Hadrian is traveling and so the court goes with him. Right. So both the captain of the Praetorians and the chief secretary, they all have to go. And something terrible happens in Britain and they're sacked. Yes. Have they been rude to Hadrian's wife? Is that it?
关于去不列颠的事，你基本上永远不应该去不列颠，因为苏埃托尼乌斯和塞普蒂丘斯·克拉鲁斯也和哈德良一起去了不列颠。是的，当然，因为哈德良在巡游，所以宫廷也随他同行。没错。因此，禁卫军统领和高级秘书，他们都必须去。而在不列颠发生了可怕的事情，他们被解雇了。是的。他们是对哈德良的妻子无礼了吗？是这样吗？
No, they seem to have been involved in some mysterious way in a kind of sex scandal. So there's a later life of Hadrian that says that they had at that time behaved in the company of Hadrian's wife, Sabina, in their association with her in a more informal manner than respect for a court household demanded. So unclear, but I mean, it clearly highlights for Suetonius the fact that getting on the wrong side of an emperor and his wife and being embroiled in their intimate relationship is not a good thing. Will it kind of be that bad a scandal because they're not executed? No, but he's dismissed and so he seems to retire to his villa and basically that's the
不，他们似乎以某种神秘的方式卷入了一桩性丑闻。因此，后来的一部关于哈德良的传记说，他们在那个时候陪伴哈德良的妻子萨宾娜（Sabina）时，即他们与她的交往方式，比宫廷家眷所要求的尊重更为随便。所以不是很清楚，但我的意思是，这显然对苏埃托尼乌斯突显了一个事实，即惹恼一个皇帝和他的妻子并卷入他们私密的关系中绝非好事。这会是一种如此严重的丑闻吗，因为他们并没有被处决？没有，但他被免职了，所以他似乎退隐到自己的别墅里，基本上这就是
last we know of him. But presumably he uses his time to maybe write the lives of the Caesars. And so there's not a huge amount to go on there, but there's enough, I think, to make you kind of see the attitudes that he seems to have brought to the writing of these biographies. So he's a scholar, he has a kind of very deep kind of interest in a broad range of subjects. He has a lack of military experience, he doesn't seem to have served with the army and his knowledge of military affairs and the lives isn't brilliant. Clearly very familiar with libraries and archives. He understands how power works at the heart of the Roman state and he knows what it is to be the
我们关于他的最后所知。但据推测，他利用自己的时间来写《凯撒传》。因此，那里没有大量可资依据的材料，但有足够的材料，我认为，能让你看出他在撰写这些传记时所秉持的态度。所以他是一个学者，他对广泛的学科有着非常深厚的兴趣。他缺乏军事经验，他似乎没有在军队服役过，他对军事事务和生平的了解并不算出色。显然对图书馆和档案非常熟悉。他理解权力如何在罗马国家的心脏运作，并且他知道成为凯撒愤怒的牺牲品是怎样的体验。当然，正如我们所说，他知道性可以被武器化，可以被利用并用来对抗人们。
victim of the anger of a Caesar. And of course, as we said, he knows that sex is something that can be weaponized, that can be kind of exploited and turned against people. So just on this issue of sex, this is the thing that will, when people first read The Lives of the Caesars, especially if they're young and they're sort of really into the Roman, so I remember having this book when I was 13 or so, having it for Christmas, I went to my grandfather's house and I had it with me, it's, you know, all very good, he's reading a Penguin classic.
所以正是在这个关于性的问题上，当人们第一次读到《凯撒传》时，尤其是如果他们还年轻，并且对罗马非常着迷——所以I还记得我大约13岁左右时拥有这本书，圣诞节时得到的，我去了我祖父的家，我把它带在身边，你知道的，这很好，他正在读企鹅经典丛书。
And I can remember sitting there reading through it and kind of going really red. Oh God, I hope they don't find out. It's really, really strong stuff. Some of it. It really is. Yes. Is Suetonius, do you think, peculiarly fascinated in it or is he typical? Does he tell us something about Roman society and culture more broadly? He has an almost kind of anthropological interest in sex that I think is quite unusual. But Suetonius is interested in all kinds of subjects like that. So although lives of the Caesar, it's not actually complete, we're missing the beginning of the life of Julius Caesar, but it's pretty much intact. We have fragments
我能记得自己坐在那里通读这本书，脸变得通红。噢天哪，我希望他们没发现。这真的是非常、非常劲爆的内容。有些部分确实如此。是的。你认为苏埃托尼乌斯对它有着特殊的迷恋，还是他很典型？他是否向我们传达了关于更广泛的罗马社会和文化的某些信息？他对性有一种几乎可以说是人类学式的兴趣，我认为这很不寻常。但苏埃托尼乌斯对所有这类主题都很感兴趣。因此，尽管《凯撒传》实际上并不完整，我们遗失了《尤利乌斯·凯撒传》的开头，但它基本上是完整的。我们拥有
of a few others of works, but we have a list of all the subjects that Suatone has tackled and they're incredibly eclectic. So he writes a series of lives of the great courtesans, for instance. So that is a reflection, obviously, of his interest in sex, but he also writes about children's games, about the character of insults, about different styles of dress, about public spectacles. And these are all themes that are evident in his Lives of the Caesars. And I think that that is because he assumes that there's no aspect of his subjects lives so insignificant that it doesn't shed light on their nature. And also that how an emperor relates, say, to public spectacles or to dress or whatever, or to sex, that this situates him within the broader cultural context of Rome, that it highlights
其他几部作品的一些残篇，但我们有一份苏埃托尼乌斯涉猎过所有主题的清单，它们极其丰富多彩。例如，他写了一系列伟大名妓的传记。所以这显然反映了他对性的兴趣，但他也写儿童游戏、侮辱的特征、不同的着装风格、公众奇观。这些都是在他的《凯撒传》中显而易见的母题。我认为这是因为他认为他的传记主角的生活中没有任何一个方面是如此微不足道，以至于不能照亮他们的本性。而且，皇帝如何与公共奇观、着装或诸如此类的事物，或者与性发生联系，这使他置身于罗马更广泛的文化背景之中，这凸显了一个男人的道德品质。
a man's moral character. And the Romans are a very moral people. And Suetonius is actually, despite his prurient reputation, is a very moral writer. When he approves of behaviour, he says so, and when he disapproves of it, he really lets you know. And you make the point in the introduction, don't you, that the Romans didn't have the distinction that we had between private and public. So the idea that we have, which is that you have a public face, but you also have a private life and you have a right to a private life, would have struck them as absolutely bizarre, absurd and meaningless, because because to them the idea of
罗马人是一个非常注重道德的民族。而苏埃托尼乌斯实际上，尽管他有着好色的名声，却是一位非常重道德的作家。当他赞同某种行为时，他会直言不讳；而当他反对时，他真的会让你知道。你在引言中也提出了这一点，不是吗？罗马人没有我们所拥有的那种私人与公众之间的区别。因此，我们所拥有的那种观念，即你有一个公众形象，但你也有一个私生活，并且你有权拥有私生活，这对他们来说是绝对怪异、荒谬且毫无意义的，因为对他们而言，隐私的概念
privacy in and of itself was perverted and sinister and weird. Yes. So if you have a craving for privacy, it is assumed the only reason that you have that is because you were getting up to disgusting things. Fred. You are a sexual pervert. That's why you would want to lead your life privately. At the same time, people are always studying how people conduct themselves sexually in public to look for signs again of kind of moral degeneracy. So it means that every Roman has to tread a kind of a real tight rope between making it seem that he has something to hide and displaying behavior
本身就是一种变态、险恶和怪异的东西。是的。因此，如果你对隐私有着强烈的渴望，人们就会认为你之所以会有这种渴望，唯一的理由是因为你在搞一些令人作呕的勾当。弗雷德。你是一个性变态者。这就是为什么你想过隐秘的生活。与此同时，人们总是在研究人们在公共场合如何表现自己的性行为，以寻找道德沦丧的迹象。这意味着每一个罗马人都在走钢丝，一方面要避免让人觉得他有什么不可告人的秘密，另一方面又要展示那些
that might make him the object of venomous gossip. And if this is a challenge for the average Roman, then of course it's even more of a challenge for a Caesar because how he presents himself to the world is kind of fundamental to how he will be understood by the world. Right, and that brings us on to those characters that we'll be doing in the next three episodes, Tiberius, Caligula and Claudius. Because in each case, Suetonius makes a series of kind of punchy allegations about what we would call their private lives. And how much can we trust what Suetonius is telling us? So for example, about Caligula getting up to Nogord or Tiberius's filthy habits, is this part of a kind of literary tradition? So in other words, it's just invented, it's propagandistic, it's political spin effectively. And how much
可能让他成为恶毒流言蜚语对象的行为。如果这对普通罗马人来说是一个挑战，那么对凯撒来说当然就更是一个挑战了，因为他如何向世界展现自己，是他如何被世界所理解的基础。没错，这就引出了我们将在接下来三集中讨论的那些人物：提比略、卡利古拉和克劳迪乌斯。因为在每一种情况下，苏埃托尼乌斯都对我们所谓的他们的私生活提出了一系列尖锐的指控。我们能多大程度上信任苏埃托尼乌斯告诉我们的事呢？比如关于卡利古拉胡作非为，或者提比略肮脏的习惯，这是否是某种文学传统的一部分？换句话说，这只是虚构的、宣传性的、实际上是政治转折（政治公关）吗？你认为这在多大程度
do you think it's grounded in the reality of what must have been a very different kind of sexual culture to our own? We'll be exploring those questions in the episodes we're going to do on Tiberius and then Caligula. And the thing that's, I think, very interesting about those two men and why they make such good paired biographies is that in a way they illustrate the two extremes of how the Romans would identify sexual depravity. So Tiberius is a man who ends up retiring to Capri. It's an island. He's isolated. And so it is assumed, I think, for entirely understandable reasons once you understand how the Romans judged a great man's craving for privacy,
上植根于那种必定与我们截然不同的性文化的现实之中？我们将在接下来关于提比略然后是卡利古拉的剧集中探讨这些问题。我认为关于这两个人非常有趣的一点，以及为什么他们能成为如此绝妙的成对传记的原因在于，在某种程度上，它们展示了罗马人如何识别性堕落的两个极端。因此，提比略是一个最终隐退到卡普里岛的人。那是一个岛屿。他是孤立的。因此人们认为，一旦你理解了罗马人是如何评判一个伟人的隐私渴望的，这出于完全可以理解的原因——
that if he's on this island and he stays there for years, he must be getting up to no good. And from that, it's a very easy development to start imagining what he's been getting up to no good. And from that, it's a very easy development to start imagining what he's been getting up to on his island. What's the worst he could be doing? He's probably doing that. And Caligula, of course, is the opposite extreme because even more than Nero, he is an emperor who's supposed to have made a point of kind of parading his deviancies and positively exalting in them. So this is a man who, according to Suetonius, sleeps with one of his sisters, pimps the others out, dresses up as a woman,
如果他在这个岛上并且一待就是好几年，他一定在干什么坏事。由此，开始想象他在自己的岛上一直在干什么坏事，是一个非常容易发展的方向。他能做的最糟糕的事是什么？他可能正在做那个。而卡利古拉，当然则是另一个极端，因为甚至比尼禄更甚，他是一个据说刻意炫耀其变态行为并积极陶醉其中的皇帝。所以根据苏埃托尼乌斯的说法，这是一个与自己的一个姐姐发生性关系、把其他姐姐拉皮条推出去、女装打扮的男人，
completely shocking behavior for a Roman, goes to banquets and appraises the wives of his guests as though they're slaves. And so again, this is shocking and it's either meant to be shocking, I, Caligula is intending it, or it's expressive of kind of attitudes to Caligula that may have deeper roots. And again, we'll kind of explore that when we come to the life of Caligula. But the fact that gossip is being reported of these emperors, the gossip itself may not be true, but the fact that the gossip is being reported does tell you quite a lot, maybe about the emperors, but definitely about the kind of the cultural context in which those emperors are functioning, I think. Well, on that point about cultural context, obviously one problem that we have reading
这对于一个罗马人来说是极其令人震惊的行为，他去参加宴会，并像对待奴隶一样评价他客人的妻子。所以再次强调，这很震惊，而且它要么本来就是旨在令人震惊，也就是说卡利古拉是有意的，要么它表达了对卡利古拉的某种态度，这些态度可能有着更深的根源。同样，当我们讲到卡利古拉的生平时，我们会对此进行探讨。但关于这些皇帝的流言蜚语被报道出来这一事实，流言本身可能并非事实，但流言被报道这一事实确实能说明很多问题，也许是关于皇帝本身的，但绝对是关于这些皇帝在其中运作的文化背景的，我认为。嗯，关于文化背景这一点，显然我们在阅读
this is that our understanding of sexual morality, as it were, and in fact, our understanding of sexuality more broadly, is completely at odds with the Romans understanding. So for example, you made the point that they would have had no sense of the terms that we use, heterosexual and homosexual, that would have just seemed weird and baffling to them. Is that right? Yeah, we touched on this in the episode we did on Hadrian and Antinous actually, but just to reiterate, the notion of there being heterosexual and homosexual conditions, instincts, inclinations,
时遇到的一个问题是，我们对性道德的理解，以及事实上我们对性更广泛的理解，与罗马人的理解完全格格不入。例如，你曾指出，他们不会有我们所使用的“异性恋”和“同性恋”这些词汇的概念，这对他们来说会显得既奇怪又令人费解。是这样的吗？是的，我们在关于哈德良和安提诺斯的剧集中其实已经触及过这一点，但重申一下，存在异性恋和同性恋这种状况、本能、倾向的概念，
this is a modern categorization. The Romans certainly had no sense of that whatsoever. Of course, Suetonius may note that one emperor's tastes runs exclusively to women and another's runs exclusively to men, but he doesn't attach any kind of moral significance to it. He doesn't see it as fundamental to the identity of an emperor. It's just, it's an interesting incidental detail. So Suetonius says of Claudius, he notes, he never slept with men, although his appetites when it came to women were voracious. And then of Galba, he says he preferred sex with males, although only with fully grown, well-muscled ones. And it's as though Suetonius is describing
这是一种现代的分类。罗马人当然完全没有这种概念。当然，苏埃托尼乌斯可能会指出，一个皇帝的爱好完全是女性，而另一个则是男性，但他并没有赋予它任何道德意义。他不认为这是皇帝身份的核心。这只是，这是一个有趣的顺便提及的细节。因此苏埃托尼乌斯在谈到克劳迪乌斯时，他指出，他从不与男性发生性关系，尽管他在女性方面的胃口是饕餮般的。然后关于加尔巴，他说他更喜欢与男性的性关系，尽管只喜欢成年且肌肉发达的男性。这就像苏埃托尼乌斯在描述
a preference that a man might have for blonde women or for brunettes. It's on that level. It's not fundamental to their identity. And so that makes the kind of the sexual landscape that you see in Suetonius' lives, I think, very strange to us. And what makes it even stranger and I think pretty unsettling is that the sexual order that Suetonius is taking for granted in his biographies is founded on an assumption that all Romans take for granted, namely a man in a position of power. So not just an emperor, but a free male Roman citizen, is not just entitled, but expected to exploit his inferior's inner sexual manner as he pleases. And obviously that is an absolute taboo to us.
一个男人可能对金发女郎或黑发女郎的偏好一样。它处于那个层面。这并不是他们身份的核心。因此，这使得你在苏埃托尼乌斯的传记中所看到的性图景，对我们来说非常奇怪。而让它变得更奇怪且相当令人不安的是，苏埃托尼乌斯在他的传记中视为理所当然的性秩序，建立在一个所有罗马人都视为理所当然的假设之上，即一个处于权力地位的男人——不仅仅是皇帝，而且是一个自由的罗马男性公民——不仅有权，而且被期望按照自己的喜好去剥削其下属的性。而这显然对我们来说是绝对的禁忌。
Yeah. That is Harvey Weinstein behavior. But the taboo for them is if that's turned on its head and somebody who is a powerful person allows himself to be exploited or yields to others in some way or debases himself, is that right? Right. Because that then reduces him in the eyes of kind of Roman convention to the level of a woman or a slave, which in the opinion of Roman men is by definition to be inferior.
是的。那是哈维·韦恩斯坦式的行为。但对他们来说，禁忌是如果这种关系被颠倒过来，一个有权势的人允许自己被剥削或在某种程度上屈服于他人或贬低自己，是这样吗？没错，因为这在罗马传统眼中会把他降格到女人或奴隶的水平，而在罗马男人的观点中，这按定义就是低人一等的。
And that's why of all the mud that can stick to a Roman's reputation, and there's a lot of mud being thrown around, absolutely the worst, the most damaging, the one that is hardest to kind of scrub clean is a charge that he has allowed himself to be used sexually like a woman. This is the single most damaging charge. And it's really vividly illustrated by a kind of almost a throw away anecdote in the life of, of the mission where Suetonius is describing the aftermath of a failed coup that the mission has defeated.
这就是为什么在所有能够玷污一个罗马人名誉的泥巴中——而且有大量的泥巴被泼来泼去——绝对最糟糕、最具破坏性、最难以洗刷干净的指控，就是他允许自己像女人一样在性上被使用。这是单一最具破坏性的指控。这在图密善生平中一个几乎可以说是顺带一提的轶事中得到了生动的说明，苏埃托尼乌斯在其中描述了一场图密善击败的失败政变后的余波。
And in the wake of this, he's determined to smoke out all the conspirators. You know, he's in a mood for vengeance. And so he puts his known opponents, people he knows have been hostile to him, to torture. And Suetonius gives a horrible description of it. This he did by jabbing burning splints into their genitals, a form of interrogation, Suetonius notes, never practiced before. And of all the prominent people he accuses of having been involved in the conspiracy, he pardons only two. One of them is a senator who had been serving as a tribune, and one of them is a centurion. And Suetonius gives us the reason. These two men, to demonstrate all the more conclusively
在此之后，他决心肃清所有的阴谋分子。你知道，他正处于复仇的心情中。所以他对他已知的反对者、他知道对充满敌意的人实施了酷刑。苏埃托尼乌斯对此作了可怕的描述。这是通过将燃烧的木条刺入他们的生殖器来完成的，苏埃托尼乌斯指出，这是一种以前从未实践过的审讯形式。而在所有他指控参与阴谋的显赫人物中，他只赦免了两人。其中一个是曾担任军事保民官的参议员，另一个是一名百夫长。苏埃托尼乌斯给出了原因。这两个人，为了更加确凿地证明
that they had taken no part in the conspiracy, provided evidence that they liked to be used sexually as women and therefore were viewed as undeserving of attention, both by the man in command of them and by the soldiers under their own command. In other words, they couldn't possibly have been part of a conspiracy because they're so debased, so effeminate, so unmanned that they have this sexual taste and it's taken for granted and they get off scot-free. That's unbelievable. But I'll tell you what, the interesting thing is that the life that kicks off the volume, the 12 Caesar's, the first of the 12 lives is obviously that of
他们没有参与阴谋，提供了证据证明他们喜欢在性上像女人一样被使用，因此在指挥他们的男人以及他们自己手下的士兵眼中，他们被视为不值得关注。换句话说，他们绝对不可能参与阴谋，因为他们太堕落了、太女性化了、太被阉割了，以至于他们有这种性趣，而这是被理所当然接受的，他们因此逃脱了惩罚。这太不可思议了。但我告诉你，有趣的是，开启这册书的生平，即《十二凯撒传》，十二篇传记中的第一篇显然是
Julius Caesar. But this was a suspicion that was attached to Julius Caesar, was it not? Was it not claimed that as a young man he'd gone off to Bithynia and the king of Bithynia had had his way with Julius Caesar and everybody said, well, that shows that Julius Caesar it not claim that as a young man he'd gone off to Bithynia and the king of Bithynia had had his way with Julius Caesar. Everybody said, well, that shows that Julius Caesar is an absolute nothing and a weakling and you know, he's a nobody. And this accusation follows him throughout his life. And even after he's conquered Gaul and defeated Pompey and made himself the master of the Roman world, people are still snickering about it behind his back.
尤利乌斯·凯撒。但这曾是一个缠绕着尤利乌斯·凯撒的怀疑，不是吗？难道不是有人宣称他年轻时曾去过比提尼亚，而比提尼亚国王曾对尤利乌斯·凯撒为所欲为，每个人都说，这表明尤利乌斯·凯撒难道不是有人宣称他年轻时曾去过比提尼亚，而比提尼亚国王曾对尤利乌斯·凯撒为所欲为。每个人都说，这表明尤利乌斯·凯撒绝对是个无名小卒、懦夫，你知道的，他什么都不是。而这种指控伴随了他的一生。甚至在他征服高卢、击败庞贝并让自己成为罗马世界的主宰之后，人们仍然在背后对这件事发出窃笑。
What about that business with the king of Bithynia, eh? Yeah. So, Seytonius specifically says that this was a lingering scandal and one serious enough to provide material for endless taunts. And Caesar, of course, is a guy. I mean, he's endlessly sleeping around. He's committing adultery left, right and centre, but nobody cares about that. It's this one supposed kind of fling. One small slip when I was a young man and they judged me forever, that kind of thing. Yeah. And I think that this, it's so strange to us, it seems so alien to us, but the very alien quality of it focuses, I think, what is most fascinating about Suetonius' biographies
关于比提尼亚国王的那档子事，嗯？是的。因此，塞托尼斯明确指出，这是一个挥之不去的丑闻，严重到足以成为提供无休止嘲弄的素材。而凯撒，当然是一个这样的人。我的意思是，他无休止地乱搞。他到处通奸，左右逢源，但没有人对此在意。唯独这桩所谓的风流韵事。年轻时的一次小失误，然后他们就永远以此评判我，诸如此类的事情。是的。我认为这，对我们来说太奇怪了，对我们来说显得如此异质，但它那种极其异质的特质，我认为，聚焦了苏埃托尼乌斯的传记中最迷人的部分，
and actually by extension, Rome itself, which is this kind of unsettling, fascinating fusion of the very alien and the very intimate. So on one level, this is a world of kind of a sexual morality that is completely terrifying, I think, to us. It's a world in which one Caesar, so Nero, is described by Suetonius as dressing up as a wild animal and then falling upon the genitals of men and women who had been fastened to stakes. I mean, it's so odd. And then you have his description of Demetian sitting alone in a room doing nothing but catching flies and stabbing them with a well sharpened pen. Okay. So very dark, macabre, fantastical images. But then at the same time, you also have these unbelievably personal details.
实际上推而广之，即罗马本身，也就是这种令人不安、迷人的融合，将极度异质与极度亲密结合在一起。所以在一个层面上，这是一个性道德的世界，我认为对我们来说是完全可怕的。这是一个这样的世界：苏埃托尼乌斯描述一个凯撒，即尼禄，打扮成野兽，然后扑向被绑在桩上的男人和女人的生殖器。我的意思是，这太离奇了。然后你看到他描述图密善独自坐在一个房间里，除了捉苍蝇并用削尖的笔刺它们之外什么都不做。好吧。所以是非常黑暗、诡异、奇幻的画面。但与此同时，你也有这些难以置信的个人细节。
So he tells us Augustus had small yellow teeth and they had gaps between them. Tiberius has a mullet. Oh man, I can't believe that. Otho has splayed feet, wears a toupee, Vespasian, we're told has an expression like a man straining for a shit. It's that degree of kind of personal detail and utter strangeness that makes these stories, I just think, brilliant. They're endlessly readable and endlessly fascinating. And so, as we said in the next three episodes, we are going to dig in,
所以他告诉我们奥古斯都有小巧的黄牙，牙齿之间有缝隙。提比略有鬓发。哦天哪，我不敢相信那个。奥托有外八字的脚，戴着假发，韦斯帕赞，我们被告知他有一个像一个正在用力拉屎的人一样的表情。正是这种程度的个人细节和彻底的离奇感，让这些故事，我只是觉得，太精彩了。它们具有无尽的可读性和无尽的魅力。因此，正如我们所说，在接下来的三集中，我们将深入探讨，
dig deep into three of them. And they are two of the most notorious of all the Caesars. So Tiberius on his island on Capri getting up to no good or not. And Caligula. I mean, Caligula is one of the great biographers in all history. I mean, one of the most fascinating lives in all history, let alone Roman history. And then we'll also look at the Caesar who inspired I, Claudius, the book and the series. And that is of course, Claudius himself. So if you want to listen to those episodes right now and you're not already a member of the Rest is History Club, just head to therestishistory.com
深入挖掘其中三位。他们是所有凯撒中最声名狼藉的两位。所以提比略在他的卡普里岛上胡作非为还是没有。还有卡利古拉。我的意思是，卡利古拉是历史上最伟大的传记人物之一。我的意思是，是历史上最迷人的生平之一，更不用说罗马历史了。然后我们还将看看启发了《我，克劳迪乌斯》这本书和系列的凯撒。那当然就是克劳迪乌斯本人。所以如果你想现在就收听这些剧集，并且你还不是《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的成员，只需前往 therestishistory.com
and sign up. You get a host of unbelievable benefits, but Club, just head to therestishistory.com and sign up. You get a host of unbelievable benefits. But you also get to listen to Tom's dissection of these extraordinary lives immediately. But we will be back for the rest of you on Thursday with the sordid or not life of Tiberius. Tom, thank you so much. That was an absolute tour de force. Great fun. And we'll see you next time. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并注册。你将获得一系列令人难以置信的福利，但俱乐部，只需前往 therestishistory.com 并注册。你将获得一系列令人难以置信的福利。但你也可以立即收听汤姆对这些非凡生平的剖析。不过我们将于周四回归，为你们其余的人带来提比略那或 sordid（淫乱）或不那么 sordid 的生平。汤姆，非常感谢你。那真是一场精彩绝伦的演讲。非常有趣。我们下次见。拜拜。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。